vous voyez pas ce qu'on va passer quand
même à l'homme du jour et on refera
d'être un tour à la fin si on a un peu
de temps
jonathan davies je les fais gagné 15
places voilà il a fait quoi et
maintenant il est le neuvième chez moi
donc il était 24e je l'avais vu cinq six
matches avant de le caler et j'étais pas
hyper convaincu et je le regardais en
disant bon fait de les brûler pas les
matches pour lui et je l'avais je
l'avais placé il y avait des trucs qui
me titille et je les revues
et je me suis dit ok ok il ya des choses
que j'avais raté il ya des choses que je
peux pas dénigrer donc il a gagné quatre
places est ce qu'on va essayer d'aller
regarder maintenant pourquoi jonathan
davies est partout mis comme un top 10
parfois il est mis dans le top 5 top 6
top trois chars sarthe incertaine mois
que je suis pas d'accord
mais pourquoi est-ce que ça devrait être
un de tripy qu'est ce qui m'y a eu tout
pas ce statut on va aller regarder ça
est ce que les films pornos mentir en
tout cas dans le sien où il peut il ya
il ya des forces du mont pour sa tiare
donné d'accord ça dépasse pas trois
jours ça dépend de chacun fait un tiers
t'es pas un nombre de joueurs adverses
est ce que tu attends comme roule on est
certain c'est franchise player en gros
pour le faire on résumer un peu grossier
et sert de ses lieutenants
ou en tout cas potentiels all star voire
lieutenant deuxième voire troisième
option est donc après ça dépend de la
qualité de la cuvée windows une cuve est
assez faible donc gérard tir de assez
réduit où je vais très rapidement sur
mon tir 3 qui est titulaire nba hommes
de rotation plus plus plus et voilà tout
simplement japonais savary
le tran like me fait peur sur davy soyez
un gros train de la hype normalement ça
devrait se calmer quand même vous savez
chaque année on vend du couvent du clic
jspm chez draft roues mais tout ça donc
c'est normal il faudra attendre la
dernière moque pour pouvoir avoir un peu
plus d'avis et voilà ne vous inquiétez
pas c'est leur travail de ventes de
l'ipod bêtes des pecs top 5 et le
lendemain de les mettre hors loterie
alors faut essayer de trouver un avis
objectif en comparant plusieurs avis moi
je me sens proposé en soirée
derrière vous vous faites le vôtre et
vous voyez comme ça donc la plupart des
équipes nba finalement de filtrer que
très peu aux grands gros mot créé ce
fonds leur avis par elle même alors
notre amie de nate un délice si on va
sur son profil donc depuis le board vous
l'avez là pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
effectivement on parle de davis jo
limitée visionna tonnes délice sophomore
cette année il explose l'an dernier au
niveau de la big ten il joue 24 minutes
il est remplaçant c'est ce que vous
voyez ici il met sept points cette année
l'explosif bien titulaire star de
l'équipe 35 minutes par match c'est un
des plus gros volumes facile plus gros
volume de son équipe 16 tirs pas masquer
un volume très conséquent
quand on s'intéresse à joe reinstein 45
% au global on voit 33% à 3 points avec
quatre tirs par match donc le volume
commence à devenir intéressant le
pourcentage est assez faible et on va
essayer de voir pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de boulot parce que c'est que
du catch and shoot ce qu'on revoit aussi
c'est que le joueur prend six
lancers-francs pas match un joueur qui
trouve souvent des fautes qui est assez
agressif on mettra ça en relation comme
d'habitude avec le nombre de tirs pris
près du panier parce que vous savez que
c'est des chiffres qui sont
très fortement lié si vous avez un jour
qui prend septième jeu les 16 tirs il ya
six tirs près du cercle dit xala mi
distance et qu'il a six lancers francs
c'est qu'il est très agressif et qu'il
est qui fait tomber des fautes et ça
c'est très intéressant sur les 16 tirs
c'est que près du cercle et qui joue et
qu'il a causé lancers francs c'est qu'en
fait il a du mal à faire à à trouver du
contact est hélas un peu plus embêtant
aux lancers francs et l'efficace 77% et
après vous voyez c'est un joueur complet
8,3 rebonds 2 points 4 passes on
regardera ça aussi et 2,39 eur d'aucun
assistera ce turnover hongrois 1 ce qui
est correct mais c'est pas bon qu'on
parle d'un créateur bas normande à
l'initiateur de jeu et pour un total
brut à 21 points en gros quand on
regarde les stats avancée la mesure où
tu mates vous avez les ressources aussi
si vous tapez ressources tout simplement
avec le chat avec le bot vous avez août
matteo explorer
pour ce soir reprendra que hook maths ça
nous suffira quand on voit les chiffres
alors ou matane contrepoids fameux
montre la répartition des tirs du joueur
dans chaque compartiment du jeu donc le
pourcentage de tirs pris près du panier
les deux points long ici et là à trois
points et ensuite vous avez nos chalets
pour chaque secteur
l'efficacité est est ce que le tir et
pris en tout cas ce que le thé remarquer
est issu d'une passe décisive ou non
dix des dix premiers volumes de l'équipe
on voit ça on est une répartition assez
homogène
interprète du cercle un tiers à
mi-distance
affaire dont 44 à mi distance d'un peu
plus de dix ans mais excusez moi est un
petit peu à -1 3 point et c'est assez
homogène ni tire de partout avec une
préférence pour les migraines on voit
que au cercle 62% de réussite ce qui est
bon c'est pas élite mais c'est très bien
pour un poste ailier il vous 2,3 en six
mois je le premier tour du 3 4 en nba et
on va savoir pourquoi tu vas chose
d'illégal j'ai anticipé ta question je
le premier retour du poste 3-4 et je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
malgré le fait qu'il fasse que à m 96 et
95 kg pour le moment on voit que la
plupart de ces tiers il les prend en
secret en lui un accès au cercle c'est
un joueur qui a beaucoup la balle en
main et qui doit se crée son propre tir
quelque chose qu'on revoit au niveau du
mi distance beaucoup de tirs me disent
mes distances uniquement du poulpe
globalement avec une belle efficacité de
37 % ce qui est un bon indicateur quand
on veut savoir si un jour on va tirer de
regarder aussi le deux points le long
surtout quand il est pris en club cela
veut dire que le joueur capable de se
créer un espace de ce créateur difficile
en nba
et à trois points un petit volume mais
qui commence déjà un peu à chiffrer 3,4
sur trois matches 33 % et on voit que
ces deux tiers de catch and shoot donc
la meilleure qui prend quand même du
pool up et sur un tir de s'étirer on
gardera sa ensuite après le foot shoah
et et à 40% mais on voit qu'ils en
retirent 6 par match
qu'un tiers de ces tirs sont pris près
du panier donc ça veut dire que vous
avez cinq tirs pas made qui prend six
lancers-francs pas masquer pour 5 les
iops en gros par match c'est un joueur
qui provoque des fautes donc quand il va
faire qu'il arrive à trouver du contact
trouver des fautes et ça ça m'intéresse
et une fois qu'il va au niveau du de la
ligne il est efficace il peut
sanctionner même si un travail à faire à
améliorer
ça c'est pour le profil brut
statistiques maintenant on va aller voir
du fil je vous ai préparé des petites
crises vous avez l'habitude de ça hop je
me mets là
alors comment ça va se passer je vous
explique tout avant bourse les habitués
vous connaissez j'ai fait 4 playlist on
va regarder
d'abord on laisse en tournée est-ce que
davis peut faire bat le mans dans son
drive ensuite comment il joue le pick
and roll ensuite comment il tire et
enfin comment ils défont et après une
fois qu'on aura fait un tour d'horizon
on regardera du clip un peu ralenti on
fera des poses on prendra les questions
que ces terres qu'on va commencer par le
drive
alors comme d'hab ça prend un petit peu
ma charge et vous connaissez ma vieille
bécane la vieille machine
est ce que le son est bien lu tout oui
je pense que c'est bon la dernière fois
j'ai fait un trait sur twitter et
j'avais oublié de mieux qu ils sont 60
ans des extraits donc vous avez un fonds
de stream en temps ça me régale la cenjp
août donc dévissé un joueur on va
laisser tourner pendant que je parle
c'est un joueur qui n'est pas un énorme
athlète qui va pas
allez là avant la tête au circle comme
on aime bien dire mais qui a une aisance
balle en main qui lui permet de fida
près du panier dès demain capables de
finir ma droite que bob de finir ma
gauche capable d'accélérer de changer de
vitesse dans son drive et ça c'est une
sas est une commande heures à ce qu'il
ce qui n'est pas lui et être capable
d'avoir un drive qui est pas uniforme
site donc changé de mains changer de
direction changer de vitesse accélérer
ralentir
capable de gérer son propre dribble donc
ça va dire allonger dans l'odeur de
dribbles ou raccourcir pour être dans le
petit périmètre
l or entre temps j'ai des questions je
les prends vite fait stojakovic ce que
tu connais une chaîne youtube pour des
foules gay men si la une tu peux dans le
chat si tu remontes elle était marquée
sinon ce que tu veux tu as sur youtube
tu cherches un match qui s'est diffusé
j'entends les derniers jours tu mets
longues heures de vidéo 20 minutes ou
plus tu tues mais date d'apparition pour
la semaine ou derniers jours et tu
trouveras facilement normalement si ça
existe et ça existe une haine qui vient
de rouvrir l on parle de john allan
davis et à la commande player si jamais
tu arrives dans notre live et que tu
sais plus tu peux toujours me faire
commander leur voiture à tout ça
donc voilà johnny davis comme on l'a dit
donc c'est un mec qui est capable de sa
création d'accès aux cercles qui est des
bons fondamentaux de pied une belle
polyvalence balle en main capable de
faire des demandes à dribbles efficaces
et donc pour ça que j'y crois comme un
créateur en nba interne je pense que ça
peut être ça ne peut pas être qu'un
finisseur et d'ailleurs je pense que si
on nous prend on le prend pour finir
uniquement les actions il ya mieux que
lui que ce serait du gâchis et du coup
j'espère que l'équipe qui le prend elle
a pour projet c'est un projet certains
jeunes joueurs d'ici deux trois ans de
l'avoir comme un créateur secondaire à
là et on va mettre tes kroes qui met des
villes booker
parce que c'est un mec je dis qu'il ya
des bons fondamentaux et qui est capable
de se créer un espace c'est un joueur
vous allez le voir un temps les clips
qui va avoir besoin comme il est pas
hyper explosif qui va avoir besoin de
devenir très physique
il va devoir racheter de la masse sur
son corps pour gagner en puissance au
contact et pouvoir imposer son contact
sur les défenseurs et ainsi se faciliter
l'accès au cercle et surtout pouvoir
créer un meilleur et car ce que des
vignes booker a appris à faire ce que ça
que la ville aussi a appris à faire une
petite halte est exceptionnel c'est que
le look and teach fait naturellement
depuis qu'il a 15 ans ce que james
harden fait très bien aussi quand vous
n'êtes pas
un athlète hyper explosif vous rajoutez
de l'amade vous rejetez de la puissance
pour compenser et vous vous basez sur
votre dribbles et jean votre puissance
pour pouvoir vous créer un écart est
donc pour moi c'est ça que doit viser le
grand délice on va pouvoir regarder le
clip en individuel on va aussi nous je
remets la playlist à 0 bon alors c'est
tout simplement
et on est parti
hop on est donc premier clip je vous ai
mis juste vite fait une petite
acceptions un petit dunk pour vous
montrer que la le joueur on revient
dessus
même en 1 contre 0
c'est pas un athlète ce plus plus plus
il va pas à claquer les 3,6 hop on va
faire pause
voilà il y donne qu il ya de la marge 1
il le fait mais on n'est pas sur un mec
qui montrent le hyper o'keefe et des 360
c'est pas grave mais on aime bien
toujours qu'on parle d'un joueur nba
commençait pas le physique
donc un jour assez puissant mais pas un
athlète verticale plus plus plus et
latéralement on verra ça juste dans la
défense maintenant pour le drive balle
en main capable de driver main droite
main gauche c'est un droitier mais qui
est très à l'aise sur sa main gauche de
changer de mains on va voir où on va
pour ça donc là je change de mains je
repasse macho man la droite parce que la
défense vient bien compenser une faille
donc y jouer contre and markets et il va
finir au niveau de la moindre eux
trouvent que leur fait
et je vais faire pour ce qui va
m'intéresser
donc lâché au début un accès main droite
j'appelle un pick and roll la défense va
contester ce pick and roll donc jeu pour
feinter j'ai repassé sur ma main gauche
ici bons changements demain on voit que
le défenseur vient aider vient fermer
l'accès au cercle
j'ai un kick qui est disponible mais
c'est un joueur qui manque parfois de
vision du jeu on pourra le revoir après
et donc au lieu de kik je vais protéger
mon ballon en revanche ma main droite et
je vais finir au lait yop 7 qu'on voit
ici et finitions au lay up avec
efficacité on est ici ma droite encore
une fois je peux réaccélérer dans le
drive j'encaisse le contact et je peux
finir au contact tout simplement c'est
assez léger on repasse vite fait dessus
mais la laj une première accélération
pour prendre de vitesse le pivot le
surprenait de casser son rythme et je
peux finir au contact en utilisant
mon offre à mon bras gauche en
l'occurrence pour pouvoir mettre un peu
de puissance encore une fois une belle
utilisation du bras gauche pour contin
pour tenir le défenseur et je vais en
puissance finir ma main droite capable
de finir à s'éloigner du cercle et pas
uniquement les yeux là on est moins
gauche un départ explosif ma gauche on
le remet rapidement encore contre
marquette donc je suis main gauche
ici
contre un pivot je pars du coup main
gauche je reviens à ma droite et je suis
capable de changer de direction en l'air
et de terminer main droite maintenant on
va partir je pense sur un drive main
gauche unie sous main gauche mais vous
confirmer on va regarder ça tout de
suite alors voilà je change de direction
je parlais à gauche
j'encaisse et je vais finir alors est-ce
qu'on est entre autres qu'on est moins
gauche ici on le regarde et à la fin
on est moins de retourner qu'on revient
sur sa main droite parce qu'on a nous a
une belle protection cercle ici et donc
je me débarrasse du défenseur et je
finis ma droite avec efficacité
aux plats ici main gauche voit la
finition main gauche je trouve pas les
lieux derrière mais je tourne sur la
faute non je suis capable d'avoir deux
lancers-francs
arrêts et départs main gauche et cette
fois ci je finis ma gauche donc on l'a
vu c'est un joueur qui a déjà des très
bons fondamentaux qui est capable de
finir dès demain de changer de mains
d'encaisser du contact de changer de
direction d'accélérer bref toutes les
armes pour pouvoir se créer un axe aux
poignets et devenir un créateur au
niveau supérieur maintenant
je suis là on l'a déjà vu on l'a déjà vu
alors non mais ça c'est plus par dont la
partie difficile pour ce jour
comme on a dit qu'ils étaient pas
explosif pour l'instant il fait 88 kg
donc des fois il ya un problème de masse
au niveau de l'impact c'est encore
quelque chose qu'on va travailler pour
ça que je dis donc s'ajouter de la masse
lorsqu'il est bien contester ici par un
pivot on a du mal des fois rentré dedans
et donc on a des tiers comme ça
difficile là c'est contester mais ça on
n'attire des fois qu'ils sont contestés
qui sont difficiles et où le joueur
n'est pas en efficacité dès que le
défenseur direct peut résister au défi
physique et
lui supprime sexe et au drive et bien
choisir les directions c'est ce qu'il
aura en nba on pense au match des bulles
on pense aux
mêmes marcus marton pense oh je sais pas
qui vous voulez toutes les équipes à nos
raisons à souiller dits
extérieurs ou ailier qui pourront
résister au physique et le tenir
puisqu'il est pas hyper avec l'explosif
et donc ça peut devenir difficile pour
lui à ce niveau là pour ça que moi
j'aimerais que ce corps à 90 kg au bout
de trois ans il passe 95 98 s'approchent
eux mêmes défauts part peut-être des 100
kg
et du coup le faire jouer
offensivement en tout cas le faire jouer
post 3 4 parce qu'ils sont toutes des
fonds sur des alliés on verra aussi pour
la problèmes de vitesse latéral
ils risquent pas d'être pénalisé à la
mode à son équipe une frappe qui ne se
fera pas aux marques à la match van ness
march madness alors déjà wyss consignes
peut faire un coup tu vois c'est une
équipe qui très bonne cette année avec
avec assez d'expérience et une bonne
relation intérieur extérieur beaucoup de
tiers donc y'a moyen qui face à un coup
à martinez et ensuite
[Musique]
peut-être au niveau des modes classiques
traditionnels oui tu as raison quand tu
vas aller sur nba draft est ce que tu
vas les chevreuils et spillane et c'est
peut-être mais en réalité les équipes
nba le savent très bien
la marque fender c'est un événement et
que c'est pas faux pas drafté que là
dessus sinon johnny jude l'an dernier
les deux top-10 tu es il ya des mecs des
fois qu'il faudra fêter sur une march
madness qui font très très bien et
derrière regard sa banane complètement
et là j'ai plus l'exemple en tête mais
il y en a des très très connu
qui se fait drafté chemin march madness
est derrière cette ville moi j'ai plus
là et l'exemple mais non on ressent tout
le temps chez envergure donc ne t'en
fais pas ça ça peut jouer mais
normalement t'es vraiment de minimes
comme facteur
il aurait dû être top 10 d'ailleurs
johnny jude aig alors il l'aurait dû moi
je suis pas d'accord avec ça il aurait
peut-être pu mais s'il y est pas allé
séquelles sur une bonne raison
johnny bien que je la dore mais je les 6
400 euros mon board jeu les fans premier
tour personnellement
hop on va la regarder la suite on va
aller regarder maintenant
si on est pas alors twitter qu'est ce
que j'ai raté voilà si vous voulez
suivre sur twitter on a tout ça si on
est pop le joueur qu'il est aux loteries
old day
est-ce qu'il est le trio day moi tu vois
je les
neuf 9 10 on est plus sur une fan
loterie qui peut sortir de la halle aux
tripes c'est pas impossible
il peut un peu glissé mais ce serait
quand même assez surprenant sachant qu'
il ya une réelle qui les scores qu'il
est efficace qu'on va voir après qu'elle
eut tiré tout ça donc ce serait quand
même surprenant
iliad est mon prêt voilà c'est là là là
de billets c'est à la vanille et la
draft c'est une si l'autre y ait des
choix un peu surprenant qu'ils sont
faits dès fois donc il peut glisser moi
je pense qu'il va rester loterie parce
qu'on est dans une classe dans une
classe de draps dans une cuve est on le
rappelle qu'il est assez faible donc
donc voila moi je suis quand même assez
confiant sur le fait qu'il sera l'autre
hic plus que keegan murray par exemple
qui est aussi très cotée qui est
annoncée loterie un peu partout oui je
pense qu'il ya une murray peut plus
baisser que johnny davis parce que
johnny davis un potentiel de création
balle en main je vois dans le chatt
personnel de bord n'était pas fair
hearst et grâce à la march madness si
voilà très bon exemple car tu n'as de
world skies se racheter jouer le march
madness malakai richardson aussi exemple
de mecs qui surperforme donc donc voilà
il faut pas laisser la march madness
comme dans des souvenirs et une saison
entière et c'est pour ça que envergure
et là messieurs dames pour vous
accompagner de a à z qui viennent morel
j'arrive pas à comprendre la hype dit
toi
je me remets l'a dit toi tu vais assez
faible score efficient profil à la
hobbit opine ouriachi moules à tobias
arlt malterie disent qu'ils sont des
mecs qui touche maintenant qui vont
toucher 80 millions sur quatre ans qui
sont hyper côtés qui sont loterie donc
c'est un profil qui redevient à la mode
là le poste 3-4 un peu physique un peu
tronquée donc ça peut ça peut
s'expliquer comme ça moi je partage pas
j'aime bien le joueur mais je les plus
sûres une après la loterie donc entre 15
et 25 mais il a des arguments là des
arguments et on en reparlera dans un
podcast et et voilà mais mais je te
rejoins je te rejoins sur le fait que
pour moi le tri c'est trop pour ce
joueur on reprend
il est vieux il est sophomore noms et
les sophomores ans killian murray mais
regarde obito pis ils étaient sophomore
ou junior lui mourra il était junior
voilà ça ça se fait mal de didier theys
sophomore on a un profil un profil qui
plaît toujours aux plats on va passer
maintenant à des visions le tir
qu'est-ce qu'on va regarder non c'est
pas grave hein tu en fais pas se
retrouver les juniors je te dis des
conneries mais je crois qu'il est
souvent noir qu'est ce qu'on va regarder
dans le tir de johnny davis sa capacité
à créer un écart on l'a vu il finit bien
au cirque mais il est surtout très très
bon pour se créer un fonds propre et
qu'elle se crée un tir et mise en scène
particulièrement il se base
sur un cross il se base sur mise d'un
premier contact donc il va souvent
utilisée soit le bras qui ne touche pas
le ballon pour pousser un peu revenir
sur son autre main poule up ou bien il
va se baser sur un coût des pôles le
défenseur recul et je peux poule up
c'est un joueur qui est capable de
passer post ben vous allez voir
plusieurs feuilles de west show qu'il
apprécie quand il a un avantage de
taille d'âge de puissance il repasse de
au cercle c'est un joueur aussi qu'il ya
du toucher
vous allez vous voyez là l'écran
quelques flotteurs quelques runner donc
quand la défense elle est très très bas
sur un drop et qu'il veut pas armés sur
un midrange qui peut juste poussé le
ballon et finir avec ça au niveau 2 sur
sa main droite pour l'instant pas sur sa
main gauche
c'est un joueur qui va pas hésiter il
est on appelle bureau né dans le milieu
il va pas hésiter à deux clubs sur la
tronche donc il ya beaucoup de tirs qui
sont pris même statique je suis face à
toi je m'élève je tire ya une belle
élévation au niveau du tir et le corps
il est bien gainer ça marche bien on
voit qu'il est efficace ion ce
secteur-là ou bien un petit dribble à
steinbach un style step et je vais créer
un écart et prône un tir vous allez voir
que les
lester baghdatis taper tout ça sont pas
hyper explosif mais sont terriblement
efficace parce que le joueur utilise
bien son corps et utilise bien son
dribble donc là encore une fois je vois
entre guillemets un profil à la débine
booker
et encore je compare pas les deux
joueurs sur le potentiel sur le plafond
mais il ya quelques similitudes
de d'être capable de partir en rêve on
voit que le mi distance revue dans la
faune une bille et on regarde et chris
paul divine booker
démare des roses and voilà le lumineux
rennes je reviens donc les équipes vous
laisser les joueurs de plus en plus à
prendre 7 series avec une
particulièrement dit me leclerc j'en ai
raté d'autres indisponibles chatham à
san diego a oublié lui quoi lenard et
caetera et donc johnny davis pourra
sûrement prendre cette cire en nba en
tout cas j'espère que l'équipe qu'il le
prend le laissera faire ça et du coup
pouvoir scorer efficaces nos jours ce
secteur là et ça c'est quelque chose si
vous le draft et et que vous êtes jouera
un rôle de finition catch and shoot
c'est se priver de cette arme qui est
qui est très développée chez ce joueur
est donc c'est du gâchis encore une fois
drafté
c'est avoir une carte d'identité fait
avoir en projet et donc c'est pas juste
regarder impotence une potentialité des
terres bon ben voilà il fera 7 bien
faut avoir un projet nous j'espère que
l'équipe qui devra obtenir davis ne
l'utilisera pas pour être un finisseur
haut en fin de chaîne mais un créateur
au bout de sa 2è 3è année quittait ce
qui commence par jouer avec des bancs
nba etc
il donne la preuve qu'il en coûte rôle
qu intéressant où elle y fait des très
très bon choix il sait quand elle est au
cercle conscrée son décalage
comme il est capable de driver dès
demain c'est pas un mec qui est
latéralisé dans le sens où main droite
je vais au cercle main gauche couleurs
comme beaucoup de joueurs
malheureusement on
antillais vous savez que ce soit de même
où renault chaillac badji mais au chalet
gbadji pour le moment pour moi c'est
plus un finisseur
qu'un créateur contrairement à 2010
parce que quand tu le mets main gauche
et papoul up un droit divin au cercle
lui il est capable d'y aller d2 les
façons assez as équivalente est encore
une fois très en vogue en équilibre très
bien et est capable de trouver des
fautes lorsque le défenseur essaie de
trop venir à l'écrin vrai car tout
simplement
maintenant
j'ai pas mis de tireront poule up
j'aurais pu lui permit de tir ont pour
le prêt forcé il ya des tirs des fois
qui prend lorsque justement le défenseur
direct alors là vous l'avez un petit peu
parce que le défenseur direct ne
l'empêchent d'aller au cercle
le compte est bien mal à vous l'avez
aussi un petit peu
du coup ils s'appuient champoux l'up
un peu forcé et ça se voit dans ces cas
là qui vient plus au déséquilibre et du
coup moins en efficacité et pour ça
encore une fois que
que je vous dis m de la masse sur ce
score pour pouvoir arriver m paul mettre
un bras en avant fermons step back avec
un vrai décalage est sanctionné ce que
les ce que les encore une fois à bord
d'une seat charden font très très bien
au niveau au niveau nba voilà et gens
montrent d'autres joueurs d'un calibre
un peu inférieure même sillage les ai
pas en tête
peut-être norman powell par exemple il
ya un côté un peu un peu normal powell
qui fait ça
ces joutes en tête de raquette me font
penser à kemba un petit peu dans lequel
sont dans l équilibre qu'il a c'est
possible après moi j'ai pas
enfin j'ai pas assez analysé le tir de
kemba
mais possiblement je te crois en tout
cas je te crois ce qui les attend dans
son tiercé que il créé un écart il est
gainé le tir il est régulier
capable comme je te dit de prendre le
tir main gauche ma droite f en tout cas
maintenant sorti dribble main gauche -
droite et cetera donc donc voilà j'y
crois vraiment fortement dans sa
capacité à créer on va passer sur du
ralenti on a fait plusieurs fois le tour
et sert un peu plus qu'aujourd'hui drive
et après on passera jour le soutien
drôle parce que vous savez quand une
bille et le système numéro un style pick
and roll et si moi j'y crois un créateur
fou capable de son séjour pick and roll
et donc on va regarder ça juste après et
avant ça le tir alors
on commence ici avec un drive main
droite ou le jour va s'arrêter
steinbach et pour le panier distance
parce que la défense conteste le drive
et donc je vais vite me crée un décalage
donc voilà ma droite la défense sur
anticipe l'accès au panier d'ailleurs
une bonne aide et du coup je suis sur un
pool up en équilibre encore une fois on
regarde le gainage de ce corps c'est
vraiment
très solide sur les appuis au plat
ici à sur un pied auquel puisqu'elle est
râpeux excusez moi ok donc en équilibre
en recul un tir très très difficile
et on voit que le jour est ce droit et
sa ses ficelles
si pareille main droite ligne de fond la
capacité par le dribble jeu cross dans
le dos le défenseur donc c'est maxence
olivier prospère le québécois le
montréalais qui est dessus qui est un
très bon défenseur qui se fait prendre
par ce cross et du coup je vais
fonctionner avec un poulet drive main
gauche
il ya deux volets là une belle
contestation par le défenseur direct et
master mais peu mais lever et prendre un
tir par dessus le jour la maintenance en
face aux joueurs je contester le job
step au début je repasse main gauche je
vois qui a pas possibilité accès aux
séries accédé au cercle et poste bas ça
c'est ce que j'aime bien c'est chose
chez ce joueur par nous je commence à
galérer j'ai ce jour c'est sa capacité à
revenir poste bas on voit qu'elle est
très bons fondamentaux ici
et du coup depuis le poste bas alors
même si elle sait très bien contester ou
vont en équilibre le fait de way qui le
maîtrisent vraiment bien et qui fait
ficelle
ici main gauche défendu par ron harper
j'ignore donc le fils de ron harper
célèbre joueur de cleveland de chicago
entre autres et des lakers et qui joua
walkers quitte un seigneur et qu'on
devrait avoir lieu dès l'année prochaine
qui est un très bon défenseur proslier
pour les ailiers
bref voilà donc défendu par ron harper
je reviens sur un peu ce tempo stop a
fait 2 way contestées ai je fait ficelle
encore une fois l'obstacle hésitation je
vais au drive et abat je vous avais qui
avait pas de runner main gauche je me
contredis moi même je l'avais clips et
des capacités la finir runner chose sa
main gauche mais faible et l'appareil
petit flotteur runner main droite donc
voilà une panoplie déjà très développé
chez notre ami john alton johnatan des
lices johnny davis la main gauche pareil
à défense très très basse je vois que
défenseur il est en retard donc
élévation poulet à mi-distance
et ça fait ficelle
donc là je suis double et
on est encore hésitation dubstep et je
vais vous les plantes à tête ah oui du
coup à 45° à mi distance
donc la ja écran et un switch est du
coup en trois points à 3 points
maintenant bardon donc on a un joueur
qui est capable de dégainer à trois
points on l'a vu dans un tiers de ces
dans un tiers des cas pour l'instant le
step back comme si on va en voir un qui
va arriver juste après hop alors il est
pas là le step back n'est pas encore
maîtrisée derrière le tir à trois points
1 sur pick'n roll c'est pareil c'est un
joueur qui va être peut tirer
derrière le dribble quelque chose à
développer maintenant on voit que à
mi-distance la marge donc à terme il
devrait pouvoir élargir la distance à
100 que on a pu voir des alors pour déjà
lancer franc intéressant ça va être une
annexe de progression c'est chez ce
joueur mais si on y croit simplement
quand en face à valeur s explique aussi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut la voir
loterie
à deux jours du catch and shoot
donc le ballon arrive sur samoa faible
ça a considéré alors à fond sa main
faible et mal sont prêtes les appuis
sont bons beaune élévation l'amc a dit
qu'elle est bonne et ça fait ficelle
ici je me repositionne ce qui atteste
son repositionnement vous avez vu alors
je suis passée d'un peu lite dessus
dans le corner mon attaquant va aux
sables me repositionne bien je demande
le ballon je suis prêt je déclenche
rapidement
là le tir ne rentre pas mais ce que
j'aime bien chez ce joueur c'est qu'il
est capable de jeu sans ballon d'être
bien placé c'est un jour j'avais
complètement intelligents et les mâles
sont prêtes voilà
on va pouvoir passer maintenant du coup
à la suite tout simplement
et à sa gestion du pick and roll abou
diab un exemple je pense que le fichier
était mal trié une belle passif anne
denis derrière sélection de tirs
douteuses pour la nba douteuses dans
quel sens beaucoup de mi distance on l'a
vu maintenant il est bon là dessus il
aime le mi distance et revient à une
bille est donc moi ça me gêne pas
sachant que on le rappelle en saison
régulière les défenses nba elle drop
majoritairement genre pick and roll
c'est à dire que le pivot reste en bas
donc le mi-distance et est une arme
efficace et doit être utilisé à mon sens
donc voilà est-ce qu'il ya trop de tirs
casse gueule sûrement parce que c'est la
star de l'équipe qui prend des tirs plus
difficile que ce qui devrait avoir en
nba
même si tu arrives dans un top 10 de
draft il y aura forcément de meilleurs
jours à côté de toi donc ça laissera
plus d espace
maintenant est ce qu'il ya des tirs
section tir douteuses parce que des fois
il ya des terres qui sont pris alors
qu'il y aurait une meilleure lecture à
faire sur la passe oui et c'est ce qu'on
va pouvoir voir dans le la playlist
suivante que le joueur pour l'instant
est un très bon finisseur
d'action genre piquer leur offre un très
bon créateur pour lui même mais que dans
la création collective c'est encore
déficient et que va falloir faire des
progrès que des fois il ya des tirs qui
sont pris alors qu'il y avait une passe
qui était tout simplement meilleur
et alors qu'est ce qu'on va regarder
quand vous regardez du pis c'est
drôlement mais à vitesse réelle c'est
long on va regarder plusieurs choses
johnny d'avis que j'aime beaucoup
quelque chose qui est assez rare que je
veux a lu énormément ses capacités à
split et un pick and roll c'est à dire
quand il ya une âme pick'n roll et que
le défenseur le pivot monte oh je suis
capable de passer entre les deux
défenseurs et créa du coin sur nous et
il le fait très bien et c'est quelque
chose que j'aime beaucoup sarah ce qui
est vraiment que j'apprécie en billets
vite d'euros l'addip auprès d'un
spécialiste pour faire ça et c'était
terrible notamment de race et contre
cleveland en 2017 ou 2018 où
il est monstrueux là dessus de moi sur
pick'n roll ensuite j'ai comme vous
voulez lady sa capacité à pouvoir
prendre un pool up à mi distance lorsque
le la défense elle va drop et donc le
pivot voiture embarque lui par son tir
il peut profiter d'un espace pour
marquer maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va
regarder aussi
que dans beaucoup de situations alors je
vous ai mis des bonnes passes vous allez
voir que sera un passage en transition
qui peut trouver le joueur concédant un
axe de vision que c'est un bon passeur
depuis le poste bas
mais que très souvent il ya du retard
sur les passes qui va rater des kick ass
est facile qui va donner des passes dans
un mauvais timing qui va rater des jours
je repique and pop et tu vas être
parfois s'engouffrer dans un tiers
compliqué là il y avait une autre
lecture à faire donc encore une fois
c'est un peu le fil rouge à l'image d'un
divine booker d'un sac la ville quand
j'arrive en nba qu'on est sur des
scoreurs
des mecs même des marins démonologie
c'est alors qu'ils étaient au début des
scoreurs individuel les mecs qui créent
leur propre tir mais
ils ne sont pas pas toujours pick and
roll capable de créer collectivement 10
et le jeu collectivement donc ça se
développe ça prend de la maturité
mais j'espère qu'il jouera avec un
meilleur extérieur un bon meneur de jeu
qui lui permettent permettra justement
d'apprendre et de temporiser d'avoir des
phases pour lui où il va créer pour
lui-même et marquer et puis quand il
équipe elle a besoin d'un peu faire
tourner la boutique tapez par un meneur
gestionnaire hamner un peu plus
traditionnel comme un porteur de balle
en tout cas deux mines en plus dominant
que lui pour faire tourner un collectif
et ne pas se retrouver dans la même
situation que par exemple cette année
houston qui ont deux arrières qui sont à
dominance
individuel ans kevin porter junior et
jane green même si on essaie de
transformer kevin porter junior en
combo là l'exemple quand je vois dans le
tchat darius à cleveland va par exemple
colline sexton quand on joue au début sa
première année où le monde est créé
beaucoup balle en main
pour le collectif était difficile début
créé pour lui tarif canon à côté de
l'usap pour pelles et des houes un
cariste les vertes ça leur permet de se
développer là dessus j'aimerais le voir
dans quelle franchise
en fait on va revenir à la fin
c'est difficile parce que
l'apport des franchises qui mois dans
son range vont être chargés sur les
postes d'ailier et moi je le vois
vraiment comme un ailier alors je dis
3,4 parce qu'on joue pour moi il va
défendre le moins bon ailier porteur de
balle adverse
donc je le vois jouer comme un trois en
attaque et défend dans 3-4 le moins bon
porteur de balle adverse et du coup
il ya beaucoup d équipes qui sont
chargés à cet endroit là new orleans
entre autres enfin faut qu'on garde la
la sélection mais les spurs new orleans
ligue mixte tout ça donc difficile il ya
l'exemple sacramento chacun cinq
semaines je vous ai je vous mets médias
sacramento aveu si vous êtes fan day qui
me faisait impression que je me fous de
vos duels et que je vous emmerde toutes
les semaines il y à sacramento est ce
que le fit est bon est ce que sacramento
a besoin d'un
scoreur créateur avec à terme peut-être
une potentialité de créer plus
collectivement je suis pas sûre de sa
mémé l'idée se développe si nous faut
regarder
regardez là dans le classement de la
conférence où est-ce qu'on pourrait le
placer mes
mais oui ça peut être une des raisons
pour lesquelles il chute c'est que les
équipes même si le draft pas sûr du jour
du fit des équipes qui montent très
chargé sur les postes 3 4 pourrait
peut-être hésiter à y aller et pour moi
le draft et pour le faire jouer en
extérieur des ventes ou kalfat défendre
dit extérieurs c'est un massacre ce sera
un massacre parce qu'il ya pas la
latéralité pour faire ça
voilà mais on retiendra la france
conclusion on va regarder du coup
ça tout qu
on va regarder ça maintenant un peu plus
au ralenti alors on commence par le
split donc je vous ai dit la capacité à
traverser
une défense où les deux défenseurs
l'extérieur le défenseur porter et le
défenseur porteur de plusieurs d'écran
montrent très haut
et du coup on va pouvoir passer entre
les deux pour créer une surcharge donc
ici
alors voilà au ralenti
donc ici en arrêtant sa va pas commencer
fut bon moment c'est pas grave y'a pas
de soucis
on va explorer lancé tranquillement
davis pick and roll
ok c'est
donc voilà ici navigation à travers les
deux écrans et ensuite j'ai une
surcharge et une faute adverse et j'ai
donc j'ai créé crée vraiment un
surnombre offensif ce qui est la
meilleure situation possible pareil ici
on a une trappe assez mal exécutée je
passe entre les deux et encore une fois
je crée une situation de surnombre alors
là il y avait mieux à faire peut-être
que ce flotteur très difficile c'est ce
qu'on a dit dans les défauts c'est les
voir qu'il y avait un clic côté faible
qui était totalement ouvert pour un
tireur est ce que d'une idée dit sarah t
il à un peu ce côté quand je veux me
décide d'aller au cercle et c'est
d'ailleurs là vous avez un clic ici côté
côté ballon qui est raté vous avez un
autre kit ici côté faible vous avez un
major en pick and pop là et lui ils
veulent dans son flotteur alors il est
capable de le mettre là le tir est
difficile est derrière fin rentrera pas
donc ici pick and roll encore une fois
la défense est très basse trop basses
capable de s'élever là le défenseur et
s'en rend compte ici il faut que ces
idylles à edel doyen scouting report qui
est sorti hier qui est trop bas et du
coup sanctions désunie davis immédiate
sera poulpe
donc là dans la passe
capable de passer quand aussi dans son
axe de vision on le voit ici
quand le joueur quand le coéquipier
démarqué et dans laxe entre johnny davis
et le panier il le voit est donc ici
vous avez vraiment une passe en rythme
qui est transmise et au nba vous sera un
dunk donc ça il sait le faire c'est par
un joueur qui n'est totalement trou noir
depuis le poste bas capable de passer
depuis le poste bas vous allez le voir
ici une prise à deux capables de passer
par dessus et la hausse tient une bille
et ce sera un dunk et pas à un lay up to
pour y arrêter là encore une autre
situation poste bas
il ya une bonne lecture de jeu capable
de passer pour sortir sur un clic à
trois points
et ça fait ficelle en transition donc
vous voyez alors c'est bête hein mais
je sais pas si vous avez assez largement
une image mais on regarde trop le sol là
en moins de transition vous avez on
l'expliquer quand vous commencez à
porter le ballon de basket on regarde
pas ses pieds on regarde devant soi ni
davis et regarde encore un peu trop ses
pieds les yeux sont pas là et voilà il a
vu l'appel devant
et on va transmettre axes de progression
ici donc j'ai une situation une sorte de
horns donc double écrans successifs
époux voyez que la passe à l'est pas
dans le bon timing alors le joueur
arrive quand même à de nick est derrière
par la défense est pas bonne et que le
joueur navigue bien mais donc là vous
avez le premier écran
le deuxième écran qui mal placé ici mais
vous allez voir vous voyez le joueur y
regarde l'ex panier seulement hélas la
transmission de la pâte vous avez un
démarquage derrière qui ai pas trouvé un
tir totalement à trois points avec un
joueur qui a plus de 40 % à 3 points et
on va chercher à une passe dans un
timing assez compliqué et ron harper
gamble un peu trop et finalement ce
n'est pas nier mais c'est pas une bonne
passe ici c'est pareil lucky qu'il
arrive trop tard on regarde ici ralentir
encore
donc il ya une surcharge côté aux côtés
ballon là le kiki votre immédiat dans le
corner il arrive trop tard et du coup la
défense entendent se replacer
encore une fois pick and roll
donc il ya là le la défense elle reste
en haut du coup le jour slip son rôle
des sens
et là on va s'engouffrer y ait une bonne
aide de renard peur johnny des 10 ne
voient pas le coéquipier tout seul
ouvert avec les mains prêtes dans le
corner côté côté faible et du coup
poulpe contesté donc encore une fois
problèmes de lecture de jeu alors chassé
négatif je vous ai fait beaucoup de
clips où ça va pas il ya des fois ça va
bien aussi donc l'appareil ou le
totalement contestée la le coéquipier il
a eu le temps d'y fois te dire en fait
je démarquer pour attirer totalement
vert à trois points jefri zeop ici donc
vous voyez encore une mauvaise lecture
de jeu lorsqu'il décide
lorsqu'il se dit je veux marquer
l'ariane vraiment date d'adaptation pour
le joueur pour le moment
et j'ai enfin fini avec sa capacité je
crois que c'est à bouger le mois du
ballon donc c'est quand même un joueur
qui peut exister sans le ballon voyez il
se démène ya beaucoup beaucoup de
démarquage du côté win ce continent qui
passent beaucoup de temps à se démarquer
à se laisser de l'espace xterra donc
c'est un joueur ce même si vous les avez
le ballon des mains qui pourra
contribuer est-ce qu'il a des mots des
marquages il se présente bien dans le
club poste bas à posto à trois points il
pose des écrans et tout donc même quand
il n'a pas le ballon il sera utile voilà
c'est une séquence que je voulais vous
rajoutez à la fin
la conclusion de ça c'est quoi jessy qui
nous dit beaucoup de turnover et 6 pour
un joueur qui a souvent le ballon oui on
a vu que ça a rationné assistant 9h14
les bons créateur nba on a rassuré
citant 9h à 2 c capable de faire deux
fois plus de passes décisives
que de pertes de balles ce qui me gêne
surtout c'est qu'on n'y voit pas c'est
pas que il n'est pas en capacité de
faire la passe y'a pas un problème de
technicité parce qu'on voit que ça
aurait dû toucher les seins jour qui
manque de vision
est-ce que c'est problématique
j'ai encore une fois j'ai envie de vous
dire il ya beaucoup de joueurs qui
progressent là dessus on revient sur les
mêmes depuis le début mai booker la
ville des roses and cdma qui ont
beaucoup progressé et limite bradley ben
il ya une limite à ça un forcément mais
[Musique]
beaucoup de mecs vont arriver en étant
ddd trou noir et on va progresser lui on
voit quand même que les efforts de
certaines bonnes passes mais faudra
juste développer la vision et c'est pour
ça que je vous parle d'un projet sur
trois quatre ans comme les mecs que j'ai
cité avant et que je veux qu'ils soient
à côté d'un porteur de balle principal
qui pourra gérer le tempo au départ
voilà on va finir sur la partie qui va
fâcher la défense qu'est-ce qu'on va
regarder en défense alors
c'est un défenseur volontaire vous allez
voir ça sarah défenseur qui fait les
efforts qui bouge enfin qui bouge bien
qui sait de contester qui qui en place
etc mais c'est un défenseur qui a promu
latéral il va être pris par les
extérieurs et va être pris de vitesse
direction de mon élection il va surtout
être pris dans les dents les écrans ça
mais qui a beaucoup de mal à sortir des
écrans donc
ça c'est problématique surtout dans les
défenses d'extérieur ou vous allez avoir
la défense de pick and roll a passé à
travers à l'écran la défense des
shooteurs extérieurs on pense au cesci
oui on pense aux
bâtiments ils ont pensé oh j'ai pas je
vais tuer des stic sciences for cannes
corps malade et c'est steve que oui bref
on a la liste est très longue de mai qui
se démarque dans les écrans et ça lui il
est pas capable de les défendre donc
pour ça que je le mettrais en défense
sur les ailiers où on a des joueurs
quand même qu'ils sont plus dans le swat
autrefois de la finition catch and shoot
et donc ça il peut tenir un jour du
drive très linéaire et sai peu de tenir
maintenant je peux pourquoi une passe
ici tant pis maintenant tony davis il va
devoir
prendre encore une fois de la masse
parce que sur les contacts sur les
ailiers très souvent ils reculent il se
prend un premier coup d épaule il se
prend un premier coup un premier coup d
épaule ou de coude il va reculer au
contact et derrière il va permettre
comme on le voit ici la poste bas même
s'ils se bat bien il se faire enfoncer
et du coup il va permettre à l'attaquant
de pouvoir marquer encore une fois ici
vous voyez au premier contact et
d'exploser ottoman et derrière il ya un
arrêt de six roues vers la chaudronne
harper il ya une bonne aide mais on le
voit prix latéralement qui bouge bien
mais
mais il sait prendre latéralement et
hercules trop contacte donc défenseur
volontaires défenseur intéressant sur
les ailiers une fois qu'il aura pris de
la masse au niveau nba
un mec avec du cui qui est souvent bien
placé pour pouvoir faire des rotations
pour pouvoir contester vous voyez là que
je peux pas le défendre défensif il ya
de ça qui va souvent de place est donc
un joueur intelligent et qui va de vous
qu'on va devoir moi pas le devant le
cacher si on est intelligent on va
l'utiliser pour s'efforcent donc
défendre les 3 4
j'ai l'impression qu'il va être un peu
limite pour le poste 4 alors
il ya deux postes 4 et poste 4 il ya
post 4 je lis randle et oui il va être
limites il est trop petit avec 96 ya
post 4 10 ntetu ya poste 4
dian de renteria post 4 me dit comme ça
là quand vous en trouvez pas ce que moi
je dois retrouver pas mal comme ça donc
les poste 4 ailier qui sont devenus plus
traditionnelle
dans le d'ici un ou deux ans si on met
de la masse dessus et qu'on approche des
84 96 kg il pourra le faire maintenant
et beaucoup de mecs qui font moins de
deux mètres en nba qui les fondent les 3
donc il défendra toujours le mot marvin
bags alors ouais marvin bagley voilà
mais bâclé pour moi c'est un pied vous
donc c'est comme blake griffin à
l'époque pour moi c'était un pivot dont
le fait jouer au poste 4 donc ces mecs
là dedans il pourra pas donc ces mecs là
faudra s'adapter ce sera du coaching
intelligent qu'on a souvent pas en nba
en saison régulière mais vous il faudra
s'adapter maintenant tu le mettras
toujours pour le moins bon défenseur
enfin moins bons ailiers porteur de
balle ou - l'ailier le moins le moins
rentre-dedans quoi tuer ça très bien
pour défendre la raison de bande sera
très bien pour l'été et tommy sera très
bien pour
qui est ce que j'ai pu avoir pascal
siakam à terme il pourra tenir dessus
potentiellement odienne une hobby
commettra delà de la masse et faudra
rajouter huit dix kilos et ça c'est que
les franchisés de bielle le font très
bien et par contrat que le corps me
tiennent donc on prend le d'ici deux
trois ans je pense que sur les premières
années va morfler défensivement et qu'à
terme ya un vrai travail à faire j'ai vu
une question est-ce qu'on a des infos
sur l'éthique de travail l'entourage on
sait que c'est un mec qui aime beaucoup
le basket à qui ça ça il se bute
d'ailleurs il avait s'était fait
remarquer par un
team us et parce qu'il est allé avec
l'équipe u19 american style des stars de
l'équipe u19 qui a gagné
la médaille d'or la coupe du monde
contre l'équipe française et il avait
été pris alors je sais pas s'ils avaient
du staff de wiz consignes dans le staff
team usa 19 mai est ce qui arrive
souvent pour les recrutements mais il
avait été très bon il avait été vraiment
féliciter par séparer père il était
leader de fond de l'équipe alors qu'on
vous en avez des données y vit harrison
g patrick baldwin qui dit l'onu a
réclamé un des leaders c'était johnny
davis qui a fourni tout au long du
tournoi tout ce que je peux te dire
maintenant j'ai pas de gpad insight
vraiment plus que ça et faudra peut-être
lire l'article sorti par maxime show
johnny davis
peut-être qu'il met plus d'infos ce nom
propre au podcast on sortira sa frappe
de recherche
énorme rapide progression entre année en
d1 et d2 à dire une bonne idée de
travail mentalité oui toujours moi et
les maîtres qui progresse je valu plus
un mec qui progressent plutôt calmes et
que enfin plutôt que l'âge voyez pour
moi un gars qui chaque année arrive et
rajoute un truc de plus progresser prend
prend des responsabilités de la maturité
c'est intéressant surtout lorsque la
progression elle n'est pas juste parce
que le pas justin pas seulement dû parce
que le gars est plus prêt physiquement
c'est pas un mec de 25 ans ku contre les
mets de 18 19 ans ça mais qui à 19 ans
et 20 ans et qui est pas forcément plus
près que ses adversaires et qu'il ya
surtout une très belle technicité donc
ça montre que la domination elle n'est
pas que physique et s'acheva les
cinquièmes de m 0,6 quand même ça a été
compliqué dès fois ci mon mieux vaut
qu'ils défendent sur les postes 2 3 en
fait je pense que tu m'as tu as compris
ce que je voulais te dire c'était
vraiment le les 2 3 ou idées et des
extérieurs mais pas des mecs qui feront
un peu rapide bas pour moi et pas des
mecs qui vont être dans les écrans tout
le temps on ne dépendra de du match et
même
maintenant tu t'es c'est vraiment très
commun d'avoir des mecs de 1,96 de 0,1
qui des photos des postes 3,4 vraiment
pour la voir alors c'est peut-être une
exception mais tu vois pendant longtemps
du jazz intégrines à 1096 idée fonds
soient les choix les choix les postes
catherine laurent alex k rousseau y
défend sur des postes 4 l'oms au bol y
fait de mettre des fonds sur des postes
quatre jours durant ce billet david et
de moi bah il défend choix des postes 4
donc notre équipe tu arrêteras des mecs
comme ça maintenant donc encore une fois
tu adaptes amat cup le but est de
prendre l'ailier qui te posera le
moindre problème en face voilà tu
défendra il défendra plus souvent robert
coddington que cauet lenard n'est
d'accord côté clippers 11 mai mais au
moins il pourra être positif parce que
il tient latéralement par qui fait des
efforts parce qu'il est volontaire
là où jour les postes d'extérieur si tu
le mets sur un cépage rénale est en
poste 2 qui peut tenir le ballon sans
être une méga star qu'est ce que je peux
trouver là facilement je vais essayer de
voir
frequenza all star maintenant mais
qu'est ce que je peux le dire maintenant
le titre d'exemple de poste 2 qui sont
pas des méga stars qui sont pas des all
stars mais qui sont des porteurs de
balle intéressant tout à fait regarder
ça
à dire kevin lui artères
des accords qui lui a tancé par un
énorme
bogdanovich jonathan s'est prêtée à tête
explosif de ouf mais sur pick'n roll
quand un écran tam et comme steam
capella ou autres johnny davis il se
fera à chaque fois enfoncée dans l'écran
il y aura dix ans de retard et derrière
ces mecs là
auront beaucoup d'espacé pour marquer
facilement et le même exemple kevin
huard terre quand il est chaud un
système de démarquage en floppy donc un
système de démarquage à trois points où
il va s'il est dégradée déficit va se
faire pourrir là dedans et les défenses
nba le switch pas sur les postes 2 5
globalement donc tous les écrans loin du
bal où il aura du retard et toutes ces
équipes là et vont le cibler notamment
quand elles le connaîtront un peu plus
et à l'est elles le des fonds seront
donc
donc voilà vraiment pour moi on essaye
honnêtement 2
de le mettre sur des skis des joueurs
sortis du wisconsin où ils feront que
font de kaminski effectivement âmes des
coeurs vous avez et hold up qui n'a pas
conclu en nba mais qui a fait un peu de
g-league vous avez ce joueur là qui
était très politique qui réclamait la
que les joueurs n 6 soient rémunérés
j'oublie ce nokia joue un peu à new york
et qui est parti après en
monarque est parti maintenant jouant en
europe je crois où il signe sa un
programme qui est souvent développe des
jours jours quatre ans
plutôt que des one bat pour prendre
réputé pour les moineaux cm3 qui
développe encore quatre ans qui brode
sérieux avec un basket très agréable
avons joué beaucoup de mouvements
beaucoup de démarquage donc il ya une
vraie academy niggel ace merci merci
beaucoup a ajouté annie te laisse le
joueur qui était très engagé pour le les
droits des joueurs n 6 et et ça lui
avait coûté une mauvaise réputation
notamment auprès de la n 6 et du coup ça
va le champ sa cote après une bille et
même s'il y était pas particulièrement
au niveau nba mais voilà sa prise de
position ne l'avait vraiment coûter cher
donc oui voilà fait un programme où tous
quand tu sors de wisques consignes tu
sais jouer au basket et beaucoup de mecs
fait pour leur niveau là
j'ai plus lourdes et parce que c'est
quand j'écoute un jour je m'écoutais un
jour particulièrement mais leur pivot
par exemple aura une carrière
professionnelle
en europe et
tana ap j'ai pas où il est actuellement
mais je crois qu'ils jouent en allemagne
voilà voilà voilà voilà et je peux
regarder pour l'un des prochaines ce
qu'ils ont comme comité mais je crois
pas qu'ils devraient gros noms qui ce
qui est attendu du côté de west
consignes pour les deux prochaines
années
alors qu'est ce que ça dit qu'est ce que
ça dit
tout vous voyez c'est des prospects
trois étoiles 4 étoiles donc et qui va
plus se trouver sur des ufr des
transferts sont des transfuges plutôt
que sur des mecs qui vont pouvoir aller
recruter mais ça fait partie de la dea
et médian d'une des six plus grosses
conférences c'est pas eu de combat une
équipe très sexy
personnes se dit je veux aller jouer
pour les badgers c'est plus des mails
dans le coin même patrick baldwin qui
est du coin préféré jouer pour son papa
donc c'est dire
donc l'an prochain vous voyez pour l'an
prochain il ya un seul prospects qui a
attendu et ce après fait trois étoiles
donc vraiment c'est pas quelque chose de
pas de facs très très très coté et
qu'est-ce qu'on a acquis et sorties ces
dernières années si je regarde les gros
prospects attendu y'en a pas un seul qui
a joué en nba quoi john meyer à la john
meyer en 2007 voilà donc si le premier
gars que je vous retrouve c'est john
meyer comme ça c'est pas possible
[Musique]
un
peu las
donc voilà ça c'était pour
jonathan davies grosse les autres je ne
les y aura oui les gens des débits stone
layton des légendes des kings entre
autres donc je peux pas te respecte le
joueur mais voilà
donc voilà pour davies attendu dans la
loterie moi je crois dans cette capacité
à devenir à terme un scoreur et
créateurs pour lui même et un score
efficient je trouve qu'elle a du
potentiel
justement sur ce secteur-là le projet
idéal il devient un bond girl like même
si c'est un projet idéal donc ce sera
sûrement pas ce qui va lui arriver ça
peut devenir en tout cas mais que avec
avec plusieurs contrats un mec qui va
mettre des points qui va être capable de
créer qui va être capable quel du qi
basket qui peut marquer à tous les
niveaux donc pourquoi pas avoir une
carrière à la norme and power à la
guérite france juniors à la parce
qu'elle est ce que vous voulez
existait plusieurs années en nba même
temps une sortie de l'ong ça peut être
un joueur qui est très coté sur une
sortie de manche sur un rôle de sixième
homme c'est simone qui met des points
qui prend le ballon son plancher en nba
c'est qu'
un mauvais scénario c'est un scénario
l'utiliser comme moi finisseur et du
coup ça mauvais finisseur d'action parce
que pour moi il est bon bah nan moi donc
le mauvais scénario ça peut être quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on peut regarder on apprend
que pour mettre du catch and shoot
globalement elle fait feu sur un poste
de alors qu'il n'a pas l'intégralité le
mauvais scénario c'est oui j league mais
alors voici trouver un joueur
la wii serait quoi la mauvaise idée
difficile de trouver des joueurs qui ont
pas réussi comme ça
la halle et un plancher ça peut durer
1000m
10 minutes ça peut être un plancher tu
vois un mec qui a voulu créer balle en
main et qui finalement jamais réussi à à
quoi à concrétiser et à mettre des
paniers bas normands et qui du coup
maintenant vagabondage avec plusieurs
contrats non ce sera déjà un très bon
plancher pour une idée lice mais tant
mieux comptez lottery pick et
le scénario 7 passes papillon
bacon
and wine bacon pen qui s'entête à
florida state qui est un créateur bas
normands à florida state et qui a jamais
réussi à percer du côté des ronettes
c'est drôlement dos et qui maintenant
jouault du côté de monaco par exemple
voilà c'est quoi le 2 le domaine dans
lequel il doit progresser en premier
la masse musculaire pour moi c'est
maître de la masse musculaire pour tout
jeu efficient
et il va falloir qu'il soit capable de
marquer en catch and shoot quand même
pas trop pro basque dans les deux
premières années c'est ce qui va avoir
le plus je pense du catch and shoot un
souci à une équipe vraiment pourri il
n'y a pas de créateurs dont quelques
mois de sanctionner sur le terrain pour
pour être efficace et après la vision du
jeu je dirais centre et trois étapes
donc année un nba mais de ces tirs
extérieurs à des deux revenir avec cinq
six kilos de plus et à detroit être
capable de mieux passer de mieux lire
les les défenses pour les collectifs
notamment et de passer efficacement
comme ça de et de devenir un créateur
collectif un peu plus un peu un peu
meilleur quoi voilà je dirais que c'est
ça le projet
bon bah écoutez je pense qu'on a fait un
beau tour d'horizon a fait quasiment une
heure sur johnny davis donc c'est
vraiment pas mal c'est d'autres
questions dans le tas différent sinon on
va pas tranquillement s'orienter vers
une période faste live tout simplement
puis je regarde ça j'aurai un petit peu
en même temps ce que me disaient les
copies whatsapp pourvoir est ce que j'ai
pas oublié
est-ce que j'ai pas oublié
quelque chose petit plus avant de finir
ou pas on peut se faire un petit plus un
peu on peut et puis ensuite en fait dire
les dodos vous dire quel sujet qu'est ce
qu'on se fait qu'on puisse dire est ce
qu'on se fait on a fait un début de live
en parlant des équipes nba et donc des
six plus grosses qu'on fait on on essaie
de se trouver tous les noms des
mascottes des six plus gros de
conférence va falloir ronger pouvez
donnez les à himeji vous trouvez ça va
falloir trouver en gros si je vous dis
exemple je vais ce pôle et kentucky
wildcats wildcats nom de la mascotte
prêté à tout va sur l'a6 plus grosse
convoqua plus soixante dix équipes ça
peut être sympa normalement je fais un
perfect l'annoncent
normalement je fais un perfect donc si
je me chie dessus
vous m'insultez forceps et là c'est le
seul but du jeu on peut essayer de faire
ça
non j'ai rien oublié
d'accord pas de souci hop là si j'en
profite instant pub instant promo faste
en province et en promouvant envergure
si jamais
vous êtes arrivé sur ce live et que vous
connaissez pas envergure page sur
twitter vous avez le conte ici et si
jamais vous avez envie de suivre les et
les bêtises de votre humble serviteur
vous avez mon compte twitter ici google
que vous pouvez follow voilà après c'est
je fais des ce raid sur des joueurs nba
juin sur peu des arbitres je supporte
les blues et des fois je mets des photos
de mes chats basse qui sont incroyables
et voilà c'est tout ce que je peux en
chine games vous trouvez est ce que je
vais faire des sculptures des prospects
oui oui mais je veux en faire vraiment
c'est un par jour j'en ai jamais 15 de
côté dont j'avais tout prévu pour les
vacances excuse moi je steagal c'était
le bot n'accepte pas qu'on mette des
liens mais envoie le mois sur twitter au
pire dans médée m genre tu vas sur mon
compte tenu que recueillait tu mens
jamais des twitter et je prends ton lire
comme ça tu me fais ça me fait gagner du
temps hop
et tu me l'envoie par tu me l'envoie par
mp je prendrais merci beaucoup de tares
recherche et de william avis personnel
et privé a fait que j'ai pas pu faire un
straight par jour mais normalement ça
reprend ça reprend voilà tout ce que je
peux dire quand j'aurai fini de monter
des tables à langer et des fauteuils et
que faire des recherches sur les
différentes poussette je pourrais faire
des threads mais à des priorités dans la
vie donc donc voilà mais tout est prêt
et je vais vous accompagner pour un bout
de temps éclipsant la dernière question
c'est quoi les réflexes pour les postes
de garde
peut être capable de
deux de partir en sucette devant moi
mais qui a qu'une main droite ce n'est
pas de ma faible j'aime pas jonathan
dernier je l'achète pas pour ça pas de
ma gauche
problèmes de vision de jeu ne pas être
capable d'encore une fois de trouver des
passes
en dehors de tout champ de vision ne pas
se créer un décalage par rapport son
défenseur direct
donc là on a vu ça mais qui pouvait
faire des écarts changé de main et
cetera mais les mecs qui sont très brave
uniforme c'est un problème
ce qui me pose problème notamment chez
john allan davis un peuple ne vit pas
d'enjeu sur tahiti à washington voilà et
après les problèmes de latéralité
défensivement pour tenir les pick and
roll parce que en nba aujourd'hui
il faut qu'au moins un des deux joueurs
puissent défendre le point taf attaque
en pick and roll et donc et donc voilà
je dire à peu près ça donc
si j'ai des trucs qui me reviennent en
tête je le dis après ya toujours des cas
particuliers
tu vois pas plus il ya des mecs on ici
et qui domine par par des passes qui
sont très grands et par leur physique
qui ont jamais rencontré l'adversité sûr
des défenseurs qu'il était physiquement
et qui après les galères exemple typique
de ce que dit dan hardy découvre cette
année molotov attaque c'est
le porteur de balle gens qui tiennent
rôle celui qui tient le ballon ce qui va
créer de l'attaqué et au fatah que c'est
vraiment le mec créateur initial qui
lance aux pick and roll qui vendent
lance la section au fond c'est la
séquence offensive c'est le premier mec
qui a le ballon qui va le lancer l'
attaque très souvent pick and roll et
même tu as quoi y'a un système être
capable de tenir le ballon et deux
passes le faire choper globalement pool
bancaire des marquages voilà
créateur principal voilà vraiment le
focus deux attaques quand pascal siakam
tient le ballon qui a des démarquages
développe xterra il est le pain est en
phase avec approprié la paix la piscine
khalil ben arfa tac mais être capable de
mettre le premier rideau défensif tout
simplement sur porteur de balle merci
hein j'ai reçu ton lien je te mets ça et
puis bah écoute tout au tout oui je vais
accepter ici team dams très jolie fille
un très joli chien en photo donc je ne
peux être que convaincu même si cissé
team cher je suis désolé et très jolie
chien photo qui donne un indice sur
l'île des équipes alors je vous mets
salah et du coup je le prends ici
donc vous avez le lien et vous pouvez
remercier juste il yal du coup pour son
quiz est comme ça vous pouvez pas
m'accuser de manque de demande de
partialité de quoi là vous avez les six
conférences victoire pickton big east
pas que tout elle veut et ici s'il est
petit causse et sens ici à la sauce
eastern la s ici il faut trouver
je vous mets c'est ici
il faut trouver le nom de toutes les
mascottes de toutes les équipes si vous
voulez le faire de votre côté vous me
muter on est dix minutes aux fourneaux
dix minutes si vous voulez le faire avec
moi en même temps bah écoutez vous me
gardant votre compagnie et puis et puis
voilà je vais les faire dans l'ordre le
but c'est pas de mettre des noms au
hasard de mon côté c'est vraiment de le
faire pour chaque fac et des fois vous
allez voir il ya des doublons il ya des
factures le même le même nom notamment
s'il ya un même qui existent sur les
simpson woody qui ont entonné les
wildcats contre qui on joue les wildcats
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de walt clyde en
n 6 et voilà on m'a écouté on est parti
top chrono
2 1 let's go alors et lors
des champions en titre dans ma
conférence je peux pas les rater et
ouest est pas de soucis kansas vous
voyez je spoile pas alors à la mefou
thibout la regarder sur l'écran vous
regardez les passes tate donc on en a
parlé
ils sont là et vous allez vue d'un coup
je mets ce nom là il ya cinq équipes sur
les six conférences en sciences tous
n'ont donc la home à ok oklahoma state
l'équipe de quelques une gamme
hockey texas alors texas si vous n'avez
pas le nom spécifique c'est difficile
vous avez ce logo mais le nom il est un
peu particulier texas christian l'appel
this is you pour ce qui est long qui
l'ont
alors tissi ou qui
a une mascotte c'est la seule de toute
la nba à voir ce nom-là
texas tech titille ou
équipe de joe wright calvaire alors
pourquoi cette amorce à m'enlever le
début prône
entre autres aux équipes de manioc
l'oeuvre de genre mais de jour là qui
sont illustrés en nba west virginia
doute donc de bellio view
sont sortis tous mcbride ou de jets 24
heures juste avant
alors qu'est ce que c'est quand même
l'intéressé pas écrire
y'a pas je ne réponds pas à houston
galles problème
l'accord et puis en plus j'ai oublié le
n ici donc je sais vraiment pas écrire
ok il inouï lorsque tu veux le nom de
cette petite je me dis
ah oui d'accord t'es chien fou je te
mettre le noir
ok indiana
équipes de l'adie peau et de lixhe
tonnes de sel langford ainhoa comme le
super héros chez casper f marie landes
les petites tortues
michigan encore un super héros
michigan state
mon équipe de coeur de base minnesota
alors au minnesota déjà faut savoir ce
que c'est il ne faut pas oublier la
couleur avant parce que vous êtes vous
êtes bloqué mais brasc de dallas nos
benton coachée par fred aubert qui
légende du coaching nba hoyau state ohio
state équipe ii qui peux vous citer
notre ami mike comrie équipe que vous
êtes dans la série glee
voilà je lâchais vraiment toutes les
références possibles penn state alors
benstiti pendre au programme donc pas
facile à trouver si vous n'avez pas l
art est difficile peu rude
alors avant avant il y avait donc on a
dit à leur personnel voire de-calais
planica n'existera
rüdiger je connais aucun joueur une big
four de rigueur mais général oublie
forcément
aller tu peux le faire tu veux te passe
tu veux ton ps aucun un porte à faux je
me flatte de par ap que j'écrive plus
vite et c'est galère vraiment en attente
de pau
alors büttner up
creighton
ad
je pense tout
oppose cette dramatique de top est selon
market
que
tu sais pas écrire en bus la
providence équipe de crise donne entre
autres
john
ok c'est un hold
the year
non adaptés 2e merci arizona state a
alors eu
ça n'est pas réglé donc je sait jamais
dans quel sens elle 6ème sa cale il faut
ni un
faux chèque leurs colonnes à chaque fois
couloudou
oregon alors du coup dis moi capable
demande et ont fait qu'avancer vous
aurez gones state
alors là je vais rentrer vous allez voir
je vais rentrer
stanford et savait pas danser bon sens
endroit là j'avais par ce maître celle
de
oui ville ucla
on l'aura je vais pas avoir le temps de
finir son jeu max et leur
nombre n'atteint pas le cold trip
fesci il estime donc ça c'est dû aussi
un soin de carl naïbo si l'équipe
d'evans blé utah
up
washington
washington ted hope l'équipe lettone
scène entre autres boston collège alors
ok allez on se dépêche
georgia tech
reste très bien
yami équipe de l'oignon walker iguane
seattle il doit toujours plus
'ainsi state de donnie smith junior et
du plateau de deron lebron notre dame
a dit moi que tu vas pas me demander où
est ben si tu fais aussi forcément tôt
fighting afin qu'ils fassent tous la
guerre très bien j'ai pu avec car donc
c'est bien
pittsburgh
où l'eau pittsburgh gemmage
n'importe quoi tu mets des bêtises sur
accuse au pis si
virgin
[Musique]
vient dignité
au québec forêt alan wake fraises
lagarde pour la fin parce que je sais
jamais mordre et ça me saoule
donc si je ne triche pas c'est juste que
je mène mais pour la fin
les chapeaux là ça me saoule
ici floride du coup
ici
mississippi
mais admissible il est plus la honte
up
tennessee
texas et y n aimes
ou tu l'as
où tu es nul
attends je fais
merci
mississippi
au lenovo wake forrest alors
alors nous donc c'est lui dial es
puis qu'il n'a pas
alors non sinon l'autre sens
ok c'est ça mississippi mississippi
miskine ici city mississippi
à mississippi 1002 mississippi 3
mississippi rade
non mais j'ai déjà mis
alors
non c'est mississippi state
mississippi
les bâtards pond
hockey c'est en fait c'est olé miss var
est d'accord c'est olé miss est ce que
j'ai fait la liste en fait pour vous
dire comment j'ai fait j'ai fait la
liste
dans ma tête de toutes les équipes de la
haye si si et je trouvais pas
mississippi en fait c'est olé miss donc
je me suis dit manquer celle là et voilà
tout simplement bon bah écoutez j'ai
fait le par le perfect il me reste 43
secondes au timer c'est pas trop mal je
m'en sors pas mal donc bas du bourg est
à peu près une minute pour celui qu'ils
l'ont fait qu'ils ont fait de leur côté
et puis vous me dites combien vous avez
fait l'important
vous voyez la moyenne de ces 5 79% si
vous en avez déjà pas mal c'était bien
solide leader merci beaucoup j'ai pas
flex j'ai pas flec là dessus
parce que
d'une part j'ai eu à forcer face et les
commandants à force de regarder des
matchs forcément bafa rentrer à force de
suivre des jours de rentrée les fiches
bas ça rentre et puis moi c'est un truc
que j'aime bien ça autant à l'âne il est
hyper fort pour refaire toutes les draf
de trouver les jours et c'est tout c'est
son truc autant les noms de fac c'est
plus le mien normalement sur les 350 et
une équipe de première division
je peux retrouver
200-250 je pense donc les high médor et
en fait si je les ai si je fais en
mettant jusqu'à tous les noms
c'était si je vais pas fac par fac mais
je fais juste tous les dons que je
connais je les trouve quasiment tout je
pense moi il y avait fait faire donc
donc voilà mais mais c'est gentil de
votre part après ça dans ma vie avoue
dans ma vie de tous les jours ça va être
pas trop hein je ne dis pas et tu
connais le nom de l'équipe de virginia
tech non à ça mais pas vraiment à
briller en société ça fait juste passer
pour un gros en europe ce que je suis
pour le basket donc voilà simplement
bon bah écoute et on va s'en arrêter là
ma s'arrêter là on va se dire aurevoir
moi j'ai
ça fait qu'au bâton que tu suis là ici
et
que je la suis la première fois que je
regarde l'aide s'ils essaient quand
fredrik berg deviennent coach des bulls
parce que je veux regarder il était à
new west est coté à wall street et donc
je vous la regardez comment ils jouer et
donc je les regardais sur ce qu'ils
faisaient en six ans et j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à dessus après mon équipe
elle pue la merde du coup je me suis dit
faut que je regarde un petit peu ce qui
va arriver moi je faisais beaucoup de
tact type de trucs donc que seagate ou
pour pour mes potes et je me suis dit
vas-y que je regarde les nouveaux
joueurs et j'ai aussi mis à regarder et
il ya notamment match des prix de 10 en
première année qui m'a fait kiffer de
ouf je me suis dit vas y je regardais de
tous les matchs de michigan state et de
fil en aiguille à 500 tu es donc depuis
que m oui disent les freshmen annecy et
je regarde vraiment beaucoup et combien
de temps que je fais du scouting il
porte un peu sérieux
trois quatre ans à peu près à l'achat
cannes et j'ajoute des trucs donc cette
année c'est l'année où je suis plus
abouti l'an dernier j'étais je trouve
que j'étais déjà pas trop mal il ya deux
ans c'était sympa mais j'avais pas mal
de lacunes et chaque année on rajoute
des steppes et chaque année on voit de
plus en plus de joueurs j'ai deux des
automatismes et tout donc
peut-être qu'un jour je vous dirai pas
trop de conneries
je t'imagine bien deux modèles t elle
être que la mascotte telle ou telle
équipe au sg des flash cards ça
s'appelle donc je te montre l'image et
hop je dois me dégainer le tu vois genre
scènes de vie lycéenne aux states boum
je les forme les formes ils seront pas
comptés ils ont cinq ans et cinq sinon
ils n'auront pas compté mais seront
imbattables en six ans mascotte voilà
j'ai des priorités s'il fait mon propre
programme c'est des écoles monte à chier
voilà bon bah écoutez je vais vous
laisser la merci d'avoir été si nombreux
jusqu'au bout pour ceux qui sont sur la
tim ripley merci de nous avoir suivis
jusqu'au bout elle fait des gros bisous
on se tient au courant sur les réseaux
sociaux tous les jours envergure un
article scouting report par jour ça
continue de ça jusqu'à la fin de l'année
et puis moi de mon côté j'essaye d'ester
de vous divertir de mon mieux soit un
live soit en podcasts et des podcasts
qui vont arriver soit sur twitter donc
n'hésitez pas à suivre notre aventure je
fais des gros bisous prenez soin de vous
à tout bientôt et voilà j'ai tout dit sa
monnaie pour accrocher tout simplement
tirer tous